all right good morning um what I'm going
to tell you about is actually a class
that we teach here at Yale uh this is a
class for undergraduate students uh
students that are just a little bit
older than you are um but don't have
they don't have any much they don't have
that much more experience than you do so
this is uh something that is targeted
for people who have who have interest in
doing science who have interest in
making observations about the world but
don't necessarily have a lot of
experience having done so uh and we call
it real for rainforest Expedition and
laboratory uh and that's an acronym that
I I like for a couple different reasons
and the reason I particularly like it is
that we want to do something that we
think is real science so um there's kind
of two experiences that people sometimes
have when they get involved in science
and one is that they are given a
textbook and maybe you've been handed
one of these textbooks and there's a
bunch of words in it that have bold
letters um and what you're supposed to
do to become a scientist is memorize
those bold letters right so you memorize
the definitions of all these words and
by memorizing those definitions you
become a scientist but in fact if that's
what science was frankly I certainly
would never have gotten involved in it
because I really hate to memorize
vocabulary um and so instead of that I'm
much more interested in thinking about
science as a process the way we look at
the world the way we study it the way we
understand it uh and the way we explore
it and so what I'm going to describe
today is the experience that some of
these students have had the process that
we've used with some of these students
to to use or study science as a process
to be have them be involved in the
actual process of discovery
all right and so we do this by actually
taking students to the rainforest so
I'll talk about that in a second uh but
a little bit of background about me we
got started on this project uh because
of my dad so my dad is a scientist I
think I I think the furthest I heard
somebody was from away from here the
farthest away was Maryland so I'm
actually from Montana so I think maybe
that means I win for being the farthest
away um so I grew up in Montana I GRE up
in a little college town called Boseman
if you've ever been to Yellowstone Park
it's where you fly in when you go to
Yellowstone Park uh little college town
of about 25,000 people and my dad was a
plant scientist or is a plant scientist
and what he does is he studies plant
diseases and at one point he became uh
interested in the question what kind of
microbes are present within plants and
so he began a process to try to identify
and characterize the microbes and plants
and I'll tell you a few of his stories
and so when we were given this challenge
of coming up with something interesting
to do with students I thought oh how fun
would it be to be involved and get
involved with my father in doing this
project so that's uh that's where that
uh that's where that came from and he's
really the inspiration both for this uh
project as well as for uh my uh career
in
science all right let's see what do we
have to do
here okay so here here's what we're
looking for so these are called endites
these are all essentially mushrooms okay
so if you've got gone out wandering
around in the woods uh or sometimes even
wandering around in your yard uh you see
these mushrooms pop up right and they
kind of they have a stock and they have
kind of it looks like an umbrella uh
most of those are called the fancy word
is bidio mys that's one of these fancy
words that you'd have to memorize in a
textbook that has bold letters um but it
turns out there's another class of
mushrooms that are called asamy and
that's what these are and it turns out
most asamy actually in don't ever form
those well they never form those
structures that look like umbrellas that
look like mushrooms um they have an
entirely different structure an entirely
different shape now these fungi actually
inhabit the tissues of plants okay so if
you were to take a a plant you would
look at it and you'd say okay I see this
is a tree this is a stem this is a leaf
but what we can't see when we look at it
under sort of our Naked Eyes is that
actually in between all the cells of the
plant are cells of fungi cells of
microorganisms that have that have
become part of the plant in fact
curiously if you can imagine if you were
to count up the number of cells that are
in you the number that came from you and
compare it to the number of cells that
came from microbes that are associated
with you you are more microb than you
are you can you imagine that okay and
the same kind of thing is true for
plants that they are chalk full of these
microorganisms and so what we're
interested in doing is trying to find
them and characterize them culture them
and study them and figure out what
interesting things they might do so
here's a picture of nine different
microbes these were all grown on the
same types of media same same types of
Petri dishes and you can see that one of
them make something that turns the augur
completely red
another turns it completely yellow they
come in all kinds of shapes and colors
and beautiful uh arrangements and this
is what we're trying to
find okay now one of the reasons we're
targeting these is because we think that
there's a huge number of them so these
are organisms they don't cause disease
so we're not worried about something
becoming making it sick or making the
plant sick but we anticipate that these
endites these organisms that live within
the inner tissues of plants we think
that there's about a million ion of them
okay if you sort of do calculations
about what's known and what's still to
be discovered uh and about while the
vast majority maybe 80% have yet to be
found okay so that means that there's a
huge amount out there for people like
you to discover people like my students
to discover where we can anticipate that
they will go out and they will look and
they will find something it will be
entirely new to science something that
no one has ever seen before and so we
want to go to find these we want to go
to places that have the highest
diversity of plants because we think
associated with those High plant that
high plant diversity will be high
microbial High fungal diversity and so
to do that we go to places along the
Equator places that have the highest
biodiversity um such as the Amazon
rainforest okay um so that provides a
really easy way for students to begin to
do something that involves scientific
discovery all right so here's here's how
we run the class we'll do this really
quickly we have a series of goals that
they need to accomplish the first thing
they need to do is they need to just
figure out okay what plants do I want to
look for what plants do I want to look
in okay we'll talk about that in a
minute then they have to go and collect
these plants and then they have to
culture the microbes associated with
them figure out what they are look for
something bioactive about those
organisms and then find the chemistry
that's responsible for it okay and so we
try to do this in the course of about
something around seven or eight months
so we start in in mid January and then
we finish at the end of July and by the
time we're done they've done some pretty
remarkable things and I'll tell you a
few of their stories and these are
students who are you know doing things
that frankly any of you could do uh
there's nothing too too technically
Difficult about any of
this all right so the first assignment
is they need to figure out what they're
going to collect what's the project
description okay and so they pick plants
or at least write down on paper plants
based on some kind of a theme all right
so one student said I want to collect
plants that are used as fish poisons
this is kind of a cool story so what it
is is if you're uh this is all
ethnobotanical kind of uh ideas so the
native people of the Amazon jungle have
lived in these areas for thousands and
tens and hundreds of of thousands of
years they know what the plants are
useful for and they treat these plants
the same way that we would treat our
sort of medicine cabinet like when you
reach into a medicine cabinet you know
what these medicines will do well they
treat the forest almost like it was a
medicine cabinet in fact there's uh
pretty substantial literature about
there out there describing how different
plants have different properties and
activities all right so one of the
things they do is there's particular
types of plants that if they take their
leaves and mash them up and throw them
into Still
Water it causes the fish to become
paralyzed and then they float to the
surface and then they can go fishing
with a net and just pull out the fish
okay now that's pretty cool that means
that there's something in that plant
that's causing the fish to have this
kind of response and uh and so there's
that's some pretty interesting biology
so one student targeted those uh another
student said I want to look at plants
that uh are used by uh the native people
to treat snake bites so if you are in
the jungle the thing that is the sort of
biggest threat to you is uh snake bites
okay because there are some really nasty
snakes now for reasons I have no idea
about we are now see we've gone on this
trip five times and four out of those
five times we have encountered a
poisonous snake that is like from me to
the people here in the front row in fact
on the last trip don't tell anybody who
would cancel my funding for this on the
last trip one of the students actually
stepped on a Bushmaster okay so a
Bushmaster is the most poisonous snake
in South America and when the sort of
local people heard about this they
grabbed a stick that was about as long
as this table and tried to get it to
leave but that was as close as they
would come to it and yet this guy had
stepped on it
unknowingly so now we call him
Bushmaster so all right so some plants I
don't know how effective these plants
are us being used to treat snake bites
but some plants are used to treat snake
B snake bites we have plants that are
parasitic plants these are like things
one example is something you know about
from Christmas if any of you ever heard
of mistletoe okay so you hang it over
your door and then you get to kiss
whoever you're standing under it okay
mistletoe is a parasitic plant what it
does is it actually jumps onto another
plant and grows off of the stem of the
plant that it started on it doesn't form
roots and everything else it's a plant
that is a parasite on another
plant one group of students looked at
collected plants used to ease childbirth
uh plants used to treat infections so
these would be things that you know used
to treat bacterial infections of your
skin one student and I'm not quite sure
how he was going to assay this but he
was going to use plants that were used
as aphrodesiac so this is something
something that makes somebody attractive
to you so that I'm not he needed it I
should
say uh plants with milky saps plants
used to stop bleeding and then this was
this isn't always a popular one uh
plants used as
hallucinogens okay so there's a whole
book out there uh there's actually a
teacher here from Guilford who has a
student uh with the last name schulties
and her grandfather wrote sort of the
book it's called The Healing forest and
it's what he did is he spent a number of
years down in South America with the
tribal Indians learning about what
plants they use to essentially go into
trans meditating States so the things
they smoke the things that they uh take
the things they eat so there's a whole
literature out there on plants used as
hallucinogens all right so we then have
our list and the students then uh off we
go so Yale has a two week spring break
so we spend two weeks down in South
America each year so in
2007 uh we went to Peru so to get to the
spot we were interested in we took we
flew to Lima then we flew from Lima to
Cusco and then we flew from Cusco in a
little tiny airplane to Porto Maldonado
and landed on what was almost a dirt
Runway and then we got out of P Porto
Maldonado and went down to the river and
then spent 6 hours in the river on a
motorized canoe uh until we reached our
destination so we were so far out of
civilization that that's the farthest
spot I have ever been in my life from
anything that looked like uh uh
civilization so when we got there
amazingly there was a little Lodge uh
and we could stay and sleep in that
Lodge and so this is the group of
students that went in
2007 and then for the past and that was
as I mentioned to Peru for the past
um four years we've been going to this
place which is um on the Napo River in
Ecuador it's not quite as far we only
have to do let's see two flights and
four hours on the motorized canoe down
river but anyway so here's the class
from
2008 uh
2009 and the guy wearing the goofy Red
Hat that's actually my dad right
here so
uh 2010 and most recently 2011 so we've
now had about 75 students that have been
going on these doing these doing this
project with
us all right now the problem is is that
none of us are really expert Amazon
botanists so the challenge is that when
you get down there and you're trying to
find the plant that is the one that's
used to treat snake bites it looks a lot
like the plant that might be used for
nothing okay and so you know we don't
have to worry they're not nocturnal we
don't have to like go out only at night
like we're looking for frogs or
something all right but the problem is
is that they're they're hidden in this
sea of greenness and so how do we find
the plants that are the ones we looking
for and as opposed to the ones um that
we don't care about and so one of the
things we do is we actually prepare
these flash
cards okay so every student is expected
to put together pictures of the plant
any kind of information they can gather
and have a c for each one of them uh and
what's amazing about that is as we walk
through and talk to people and they say
here's the plants we're looking for they
can tell you what your collection theme
is they have that much knowledge of what
the forest is and what it's useful for
that when you talk to the guides they
can say oh you're you're you're
collecting things that are used for
infections here's here's 10 other plants
that you should have had on your list
let's go collect those too okay so we
have no idea about what our what the
plants in our neighborhoods do we just
we've become disconnected from that
right whereas they have this very strong
connection to what the plants can do
what the roots what parts of the plants
are useful whether it's the stems of the
roots or the leaves um and so it's
really amazing to spend some time
talking to these people who have
knowledge of of their environment in a
way that we we've lost now the other
thing we do so some students are
actually able to to find their plants
using this but another thing we do is we
um we collaborate with Percy Nunes and
Percy is probably the world's expert
Amazon botanist so he knows his plants
cold like you show him half of a leaf
and he can tell you what family of plant
it came
from and he knows not only the English
name he knows the name in a variety of
other languages so he's a ketua Indian
so he knows knows he knows what it's
used for for in a a variety of different
ethnobotanical settings uh and he knows
the scientific names of many of these so
he's he's absolutely remarkable so the
students come to depend very heavily
upon his knowledge of uh of the forest
and and what we can do with it all right
let me tell you one collection story so
I mentioned the bushmaster it turns out
another snake that is very poisonous and
is another one that we didn't step step
on but almost did so we were sort of
hopping along the trail gleeful that we
were out in the woods and one student
sort of hopped up and sort of in midair
realized that he was jumping over a
fertil an which was this snake and this
one was about 5 to six feet long this is
a big snake in fact this is the biggest
fertil an that any of the guides had
ever seen so he manages to clear it and
then of course then we gather around to
take pictures of it
okay now the lore in the jungle is that
wherever you see a poison the remedy is
nearby okay that's I'm sure it's a hokey
lore but anyway it's the lore okay so
one student was out to collect the tree
the fertiland tree and the reason it was
called the fertiland tree is because the
bark of the tree looks like the skin of
the
snake so in another example so we've
seen actually three fertil ances this is
the biggest one this was actually the
second year the third year we went we
saw another fertil an it was actually a
much smaller one and in that case you'll
see here's the snake and not but from me
to the front row was the tree and so
here's the tree it's not quite in Focus
but you can see why this would be given
the name that it does that it has the
shape the bark has the the
characteristic uh pattern that is the
snake Okay so one student collected was
able to collect the fertil an uh tree
that they were out to collect all right
so each student collects something like
25 or 30 different plant samples we
bring them back and uh go to work so
here's here's the lab uh the students
enjoyed this experience so much they've
actually created a huge wall mural that
goes up and across the ceiling uh side
to side in the lab of the different
things they saw while they were in the
jungle so that's kind of fun there's
actually howler monkeys on the other
side um and what we're doing now is
we're taking the plant material that
we've isolated and we sterilize the
outside cut it up and then put it onto
pacher dishes and ask what grows out so
after we've waited we wait a few days or
even a couple weeks and things these
white fuzzy things start to grow out on
the Petri dishes and th those are the
endites that we're trying to
isolate so at this point we get the
different sh sizes and shapes and colors
that we were looking at and then when we
look at them under micros under the
microsc scope we see these spores which
is how the fungi reproduce we see so
these are the different spores we see Hy
which are the white sort of stringy
things that uh the fungi have um and so
we can begin to characterize them all
right so here
is here's a question for you all right
so we have 15 students 16 students a
year that are doing this they come back
with 25 plants and this is what one
student got from what they collected so
in other words this is all the microbes
that one student was able to isolate one
year so you take this and multiply it by
about 80 that gives you a sense of how
much stuff we've now collected all right
now many of these some of these
organisms no one's ever seen before like
they're completely new to science no
one's ever described them no one's ever
done anything with them before and so
the question is what what do you do
right you can't can't look in a textbook
and say oh this is what I should do
because this is what the textbook tells
me to do I can't you can't follow some
protocol that the lab person says this
is what you're absolutely supposed to do
and so the students have to begin to
think about okay what do what would be
interesting to me what kind of questions
do I want to answer how could these
organisms be able to address problems
that the world faces like what kinds of
problems does the world face that we
would like to solve and how could having
greater biological diversity help us
solve it okay so let me tell you just a
few stories about how the students have
applied uh these organisms to that kind
of
question all right and before I do that
here's here's the question of what what
did we
find all right so this don't worry about
the details of this graph but what this
essentially describes is what's known so
if you take all the fungi that are known
and put them on a Gra
and compare them to the closest thing
that is the closest other thing that's
known you can imagine there's a whole
bunch of things that are exactly like
other things that have been found before
but the further there's some weird
things and they this is essentially the
tail of this
curve all right so if you found
something that by sequence looked like
this it would be okay that's a organism
that has been seen
before if you found something that was
in this range like the 90% range this
would might be a new
species and something out here might be
actually a new
genus so the question is what do the
students find okay so if we superimpose
that on the first year students and this
is true of the first year and it's true
of the most recent year we find things
that have been seen before we find
things that are fairly novel that this
would be a new species and we actually
find things out here that are among the
most Divergent organisms that have ever
been found these would be at least new
gener we even have some that constitute
New Order um suggesting that what we're
looking at is as we do this experience
do this uh study we're getting one new
genus not new species one new genus of
organism per student per
year so that means there's a whole lot
of stuff out there still to be found
there's a whole lot of stuff for people
like you to find if you know how to go
look and you know where to go look all
right right so if we have this level if
we have like 15 new genre per year uh
that's pretty cool okay so like this is
a pH philogenetic tree what this means
is the length of the line means how
closely it is related to other things on
the on the tree so for example
701a is clearly close to other things
that are here these are branches that
are pretty short and everything on this
little bud is called the peso opsis
microsc spora so clearly 701a is the
same thing as what's been seen before
okay but what do you do with
this so
1802a look how long that line is look
how long the line is before you get to
the next one so you actually have to go
down and back up again and each one of
these are different
gener so what do you call
1802a do you call it a mass
Arena a PLO
Perales it doesn't actually fit any of
those which means that this student had
to figure out what they were going to
call it and they actually had to call it
something new they got to name it so
what do you name something that you've
discovered what do you name it based on
and those are the kinds of questions
that the students have to think about
yeah I was about to say like your own
name turns out that's the one thing you
can't name it based on so the rules for
naming new organisms is you can't name
them as after yourself you can name them
after your teachers though which would
be really
cool so it turns out a lot of these
things end up getting named after Percy
so there's Nunes this and Percy that
right because he was so helpful to us
while we were in the
forest all right so having now gone
through the process of getting plant
material isolating microbes figuring out
where they are on this tree on the
relationship of how things are related
to other things we now want to do some
we want to actually look for things some
things that are useful so now we'll
spend some time talking about screening
for
bioactivity all right so just to keep us
in remind us what we're doing we're in
the rainforest collecting plants we
bring those home we isolate fungi these
are the
endites we grow the endites up in liquid
culture so we essentially put them into
a media they grow for some uh number of
days or weeks and they end up in all
kinds of of colors from Gray to Black to
Yellow to red and then we extract those
to so we take the funi out and we take
the essence of what they excreted into
the media and uh reduce the volume down
and create these extracts so we sort of
the essence of the
fungus and then we screen those uh for
activity so we have about over 2,000
almost 2500 extracts now that we've
generated over the past five
years all right so what do you hope
those extracts can do that's the
question so I'm going to tell you just a
handful of stories of what these
extracts can
do and in each case this is something
where the students decide like I didn't
tell them oh you got to do this you got
to do that I said here you've got access
to this you know a bunch of new
organisms making new compounds
potentially what would what problems
would you like to solve all right so
first story is sunen Lee
and she was interested in inflammation
she was particularly interested in
inflammation associated with pre-term
birth so if a pregnant woman gets a
bacterial infection it will sometimes
cause pre-term labor so the baby is born
to early or too early uh as a result of
that infection so she was looking for
things that could reduce the
inflammatory response okay the the
immune response that the body mounts uh
that causes this effect and and so she
developed this sort of simple assay in
which she put a placental tissue into
each of these little Wells okay and then
she added the uh what's called LPS this
is what the bacteria make that caused
the inflammation and then to that she
added extract and then she monitored for
the production of a yellow color based
on uh don't worry about where the yellow
color comes from but that's essentially
how yellow it is corresponds to the
degree to which there is inflammation
okay and here's what she saw so this is
this is the sort of control you always
want to have controls in your
experiments and then she did the first
10 extracts and what do you think is
anything working
here what's happening in what's
happening so
far is it more yellow or less yellow
less
yellow so we're comparing to this so who
says less who says more yellow yeah it's
more yellow so we don't want it more
yellow we want it less yellow so is
anything working for her so far total
failure so far terrible terrible outcome
of this experiment okay she's actually
getting things that are causing more
inflammation okay so that was the first
10 so then she said all right well I'll
do 10 more so and then she did this okay
anything anything working
here one exactly one that one extract
number eight is working in this case
Okay so she found one extract from one
organism that actually completely
eliminates the production of the
compounds responsible for inflammation
in fact when she went through and did
the quantitation of this okay here's the
control so everything's relative to the
control almost everything increased the
inflammatory response except this one
extract which reduced it all right well
where did that organism come
from well that organism curiously came
from this plant and it was collected by
this students this is Cory is
and Cory went into the rainforest to
collect carnivorous plants she wanted to
collect plants that ate insects it's
pretty cool okay and it turns out the
only carnivorous plant in the area that
pery knew about uh was the one called
draer Montana which is a plant about
half the size of the your palm so it's a
really tiny plant and it lives on the
forest floor in the savannah now you
might say the Savannah I thought we were
in the rain Forest well as you walk
along the rainforest on the edge of Peru
and Bolivia which is where we were there
comes a point like this moment where you
walk out of the forest and you walk into
the Sun and all the big trees are gone
and it turns into this sort of grassy
Marsh and then the insects come
out just nasty okay and the forest is
actually pretty comfortable when you're
in it because it's shady and you know
it's not the sun isn't beating down on
you as soon as you walk into the
Savannah it's like an oven it's
oppressive and it's hot and it's sunny
and then there's insects flying all over
your head and this is where drosera
Montana was to be found and so the goal
was to go in and sort of lift up the
grass and see if we could find drer
Montana I gave up after not very long
I'm like I'm going back into the forest
where it's cool um but Corey kept at it
and Percy kept at it and a few other
students kept at it and they found about
five of these they brought it back and
she isolated about six different
microbes the fact that it's an e means
there was an a a b a c a d and there's e
and then there's an F of which four were
new species and new gener like no one
had ever looked for microbes associated
with dcera Montana
before because I'm sure nobody wanted to
go through the pain of getting it like
we did all right so 404e is where that
active extract came from she went on to
characterize it so this is what the
spores look like she characterized the
the shape of the culture the shape of
the spores that's what you have to do to
name something and then she named it AOS
Feria Flava
radians okay which in Latin means golden
spheres radiating yellow now somebody
comment you commented that the thing you
do is you name it after yourself right
and I said you can't name it after
yourself that's the one rule okay
there's a scientific joke here if
anybody noticed it okay let me go back
just a couple slides so the person who
was doing this work was
[Music]
named sunin Le anybody get the
joke scientific joke they're always
really subtle right golden spheres
radiating yellow what do you think of a
golden sphere that radiates yellow the
sun very good okay so Sun actually did
name it after herself though not
quite okay so anyway so that's now in
the literature she published a
description of that she has credit she
gets to name it from now on that's
hers and then she went on to
characterize the activity that was
responsible for this so she did
chemistry where you fractionate and
purify and analyze and she ended up
getting a crystal structure that shows
us that this is what the compound looks
like this is what it looks like if you
draw it out and sure enough what it does
is this is a compound that blocks
protein export so the ex the production
of protein sending it out into the into
the media so it blocks the production of
il6 and
il8 okay so that one story so this
student got a uh let's see she got a
joint bachelor's Master's Degree for
this work and now is doing a joint PhD
MD at National Institute of Health and
uh at
Cambridge all right next story so Blair
benam pile that's her picture up here
Blair heard about this course before we'
even started offering it when she was in
high school and she came to me when she
was interested in trying to figure out
where she was going to go to college and
she said I want to come to Yale so I can
take this
class I was like wow okay so two years
later she showed up there she was the
first day of class and I was like all
right Blair if you came to Yale to take
this class I I guess you'll you'll be in
so and she did a fabulous job so she did
all kinds of stuff and she actually just
gradu uated two years ago spent a year
doing uh research this type of research
actually in China and is now starting a
PhD program at Stanford but anyway so
the work she started on was on hookworm
disease now what this is is this is a
this is a parasite that actually comes
up through your feet if you can imagine
so if you're wandering around in soil
that's contaminated with hookworm
Barefoot it comes up through your feet
and goes into your
um into your heart and lungs um and the
consequence is that when it's all said
and done it ends up in your small
intestine and you know essentially feeds
on what you eat okay and a large
fraction of the people in uh in Africa
and other third world countries are
actually infected with hookworm disease
that has some pretty debilitating
effects on their development so it means
you you end up being iron deficient and
you end up have stunted growth and
reduced heal all right so what Blair was
looking for was organism was uh extracts
that could kill hookworm prevent the egg
hookworm eggs from hatching or if they
do hatch make it so the larvae can't
develop so instead of looking like this
nice I guess if you're a hookworm this
is what nice looks like it look instead
of looking like this if the larva hatch
it looks like something that isn't alive
okay and so she screened these extracts
and what she found was one extract ra
that this is what wild type sort of
looks like one extract that reduced the
level of hatching and everything that
did hatch what the gray what the black
means everything that hatched was dead
and she found that if she reduced she
diluted this a huge amount it was still
active and in this case it came from a
known organism at least one that we'd
seen before that was known to the
literature it was a foo acrimonium from
the water lily which was in a lake
behind the place we were
staying all right so she went on to
identify what it was that was active so
she did a whole bunch of chemistry so
the first thing she did is she got a
mass so this is how heavy what is the
what is the molecular weight and from
that she could figure out what the ratio
of carbon to nitrogen to oxygen to um
hydrogen was and then she did uh a set
of things called nuclear magnetic
resonance so she used the instruments in
the in the lab next to where Kurt Z
works and from that she can conclude
actually that it was um she actually
went on to identify what this compound
is and show show its
activity all right another story so in
this case this is Alicia Darnell um and
what she found is an organism that you
see here this organism is also novel at
the genus level we haven't named it yet
but this is something that is never
never been seen or characterized before
she isolated it from a Strangler fig now
the Strangler fig is actually kind of
kind of a cool story because it's um
it's an example of a pretty nasty plant
so if you're a plant you have to think
about okay how do I make it in the world
right how do I find my place in the
world and how do I how do I get there in
the fastest way I can right and so what
this plant does is it produces figs that
birds eat the birds drop the Fig seeds
in the canopy when they you know they
land they drop the this the seeds in the
in the canopy where they germinate and
then the Fig sends down a chute to the
ground but not a root it's like a or not
a not a branch just a long
root and then what it does is it begins
to grow on top of the other plant so
instead of making its own trunk it
borrows the trunk of the plant that it
landed on and then as it gets bigger and
bigger it sends down more and more roots
to the point or more and more sort of
these long roots to the bottom to the
point where it literally engulfs the
trunk of the tree that it started on and
kills the tree that it was living on and
so what you see are these Strangler fig
trunks okay where these roots have all
fused together that are just completely
full of holes because it was never a
trunk that grew up like the trees we're
used to it was just a bunch
of roots that got sent down and then
fused together and so it looks like
swiss cheese but in the middle of that
it's completely Hollow because what was
in the middle of that was the tree that
it originally landed on okay and so she
went out to identify and to find
organisms that were growing inside of
this or this tree that was actually uh
killing another
tree all right so out of this what she
found is that an extract was able to
inhibit the growth and actually kill an
organism called Canada Albans now this
is what causes thrush causes yeast
infections and if you're an HIV patient
what usually kills you if you if you die
from HIV isn't HIV you die from thrush
you die from Canada Albans infection and
so we're really interested in finding
things that can inhibit the growth of
Canada Albans and so this is actually a
really beautiful observation that we
have this really strong level of
inhibition at a site where Canada Albans
would otherwise be growing so she went
on to do isolation so fractionating it
uh purifying it again doing HP PLC
getting a mass spec doing NMR and we're
fairly sure at this point that we have a
new compound so we have a new organism
and a new compound that's active against
Canada
alacant all right so but not everything
is about finding um new
drugs uh these three students were
interested in the issues of Bio
remediation so the issue is what what
questions does the world face what
problems is the world face that we can
solve and they said well one of the
problems the world faces that we could
solve is the n the amount of
garbage that there is out there the
amount of plastic that there is and what
we need are things that can degrade
plastic and so what they did is they set
up an assay in which they fed organisms
this compound so polyurethane which is a
type of plastic and in this case it's a
plastic in the form of a milky white
suspension so they feed this to the
organisms and they're looking for
organisms that can degrade the
plastic so what what they do is they
make Petri dishes where the media is
instead of having sugar it instead they
feed it this
polyurethane and they look for a place
where the organism can grow and then it
has this Halo of clearing you can see
where the organism is here and then
there's this kind of clearing Zone
around it so that's an example of an
organism that's able to actually degrade
the plastic and so they screened all the
organisms we isolated for this ability
and they found a handful that were
active they went on to then test them in
liquid culture so here what you see is
what we started with this is the milky
white suspension this is the best thing
that we could find in the literature and
then here's the five other organisms and
you can see that in some cases they've
it's completely cleared the suspension
all that's left in here is actually the
organism there's no plastic left at all
so it grew it made fungus and it
completely degraded the plastic and
furthermore it could do this where the
only carbon that it had the only sources
of energy that had was the
plastic and it didn't require any Oxygen
so it was an anerobic sarbon Source
growth um so just to sort of emphasize
that here's what it looks like before
six days later here's what it looks like
it completely degraded
it he characterized how the reaction was
working using uh what's called infrared
spectroscopy and I'm not much of an IR
spectroscopist I don't imagine you know
much about it either but if you look at
what's on top and compare it to what's
on the bottom I anticipate you can
notice that there's something here that
isn't there everybody see that and that
tells you actually which Bond was broken
it tells you that a carbon oxygen Bond
was broken during the degradation of the
plastic now what John was interested in
he was like well okay polyurethane
that's all fine and good I really want
to degrade polystyrene does anybody know
what it's used to make what is po
polystyrene used to make yeah
yeah yeah coffee cups it's
styr and if you bury a bit of
polystyrene in the ground and come back
a hundred years later it's pretty much
still there okay so he's like I really
want to degrade something that' be
difficult to degrade and so he's now he
then figured out a way to screen for
organisms that could degrade polystyrene
and he found one and the data is still a
little preliminary and I don't have a
picture of it but he found things that
could actually begin to degrade
polystyrene uh and so he saw that is a
problem that was really important uh and
maybe he's begun to find a solution for
it all right
so one one last
story so and this actually is part of a
story that um is begins with work that
my dad did and so he actually goes all
over the world collecting plant material
um I think he's in Australia either last
week or next week um and he anyway yeah
he goes everywhere so this is actually a
Cinnamon Tree in
Honduras if you can imagine and out of
it came this
microbe now the Curiosity here was this
microbe
um was new we hadn't seen it before
again it's a new
genus but what he' done is he' put all
the microbes that he had growing and all
the plant material he had growing in a
plastic box sort of like this one that's
being carried out of the back of the
room right now with the lid on the top
and what he observed is that this
organism grew and everything else that
was in the Box started to grow and then
died when he went to transfer it and put
it on new plates everything else in the
Box was
dead so that's kind of
weird so he said I wonder if I wonder
what the cause of it might be so any
thoughts on how that could
work how could one organism kill
everything else that's inside a plastic
box
kind of
weird so there's a smell that was kind
of a strange odor that this thing
produced okay and maybe that's a
clue so what he did is a really simple
experiment turns out you can do really
simple experiments it doesn't all
require big expensive equipment so this
is a simple experiment that you could do
in your high school or Junior High
School class he takes this new organism
and puts it on one side of a petri dish
and then puts another organism on the
other side and what he observes is that
if you take the medus this is the augur
he pulled the augur out in between this
organism is killing this one this is
just a little piece of augur you can see
that nothing's growing out of the augur
this one is killing that one at a
distance it's making gases and killing
at a
remotely okay so you can imagine that
you could actually use this to
fumigate without ever actually having
one organism come in contact with
another or having to isolate the
products right and so this is something
that actually is pretty interesting so
he then ask the question what's it
making and it's like a Aldrich catalog
of organic solvents so there's all kinds
of stuff in there um this is the
products of what it's making now the
next thing we could do is we could
actually try to isolate more of these
using the first one okay and I'll spare
the details of how we did that but we
used the first one to isolate several
more in fact we isolate these every year
and so we've now got probably over a
dozen of these muskot Albus producing
gas producing fungi that are making
volatile organic
compounds and we can show that they're
bioactive so one of the things we wanted
to do is say well what what's a problem
that we could solve people get lung
infections particularly for example
people that have cystic fibrosis get
lung infections and it's really
difficult to deliver antibiotics to the
lungs and so we asked the question could
we in fact have the gases because now
you're breathing them in Could you
actually deliver the gases or have the
gases inhibit or kill organisms that are
that are part of cystic fibrous lung
infections and so one of them we looked
at was ser maresin and so what you see
is here's the M Albus on one side of the
P tradition and then there's a physical
barrier and then there's the Ser maresin
which is red so you can easily see it
and you can see here's what it looks
like if you don't do anything it grows
quite nicely and it's red but if you
have one M Albus you don't see any
growth this m Albus you see very little
growth some of them don't produce
anything that inhibits serum maresin and
some are sort of halfway in
between so that was kind of cool and
then we said well what about other types
of lung infections what about like the
ultimate lung infection ction is
actually
tuberculosis that's a problem could we
do something with t tuberculosis so we
got in collaboration with a guy at
University of Pittsburgh name that guy
named Graham hatville who thinks about
tuberculosis and works on it and what we
did is we put so in this case each one
of these set of six is one experiment so
we put muscot Albus on the outer four
Wells and then we put a v we put media
with uh microbacterium tuberculosis in
the middle too and if it grows it
actually gets kind of thick and hazy it
forms what's called a bofilm and so you
see this grayness and if you look here's
muscular alus and look at the middle two
and tell me what do you see is anything
growing here no how about here no maybe
a little bit here maybe a little bit
there but the point is that the gases of
the muscular alus were able to actually
to inhibit microbacterium tuberculosis
in solution in in the in the media so
that's kind of cool okay so I don't know
if that's going to be you know useful
for solving the world's TB problem but
nevertheless it's an interesting
different way to think about the
problem all right so in the last two
minutes one last story so this is
another organism that we isolated this
one comes out of that same screen where
we look for things that can grow in the
presence of muscular alas this one was
isolated it's called Asco sares
and when one of the students in the lab
asked the question what does it make
okay so in that we're trying to figure
out what the compounds are what you see
is here's What's called the gas chromat
chromat gas chromatography Mass
spectrometer trace and each one of these
Peaks corresponds to a different
compound and then we can go through and
identify what those compounds are here's
the list and if you do complete analysis
here's the complete
list so this is an organism that can
grow on cellulose and make Keane octane
three octe three nine four nine cyod
Deane deine cyc
Deane and so on do any of those ring any
bells what octane octane so what is
octane what do you where do you use
octane in fuel in fuel so like when you
go to the gas tank and you fill your car
up with gas there's like 89 91 93 what
are those
there's are octane ratings and the more
of the octane there is the more it costs
right so what that is is that's actually
a ratio it's a ratio of octane to ISO
octane or the equivalent of that anyway
these are the kinds of compounds and
there's a whole bunch of compounds that
are present in gasoline but these are
the kinds of compounds that were present
in the gas tank that is was in the car
that drove you to class
today now those compounds and that that
material was found in the ground
and was you know pumped and delivered
here from Saudi Arabia or up from Alaska
or maybe down in Mexico or colia okay
but this organism is able to take
cellulose which is the most abundant
form of carbon on Earth and actually
convert it into these products which
could be in principle if we can figure
out how to do this efficiently could in
principle be used as fuels and so of
course that's a pretty interesting thing
so for example we then screen these
organisms for their ability to produce
volatile organic compounds so
Raul uh found this organism let's see do
I have a picture of it yeah right here
um which makes C9 h12 compounds which is
one carbon longer than what you get with
Octane and so we're in the process of
figuring out how we make it how we can
make more of it and what it could be
used for all right so the simple idea is
sugars in and then these alkanes out uh
with the application to Fuels
all right so in each of these cases
these are students who are thinking
what's an important problem and how can
I solve it and how can I use this
diversity and these compounds that the
organisms these organisms diversity
produce to find solutions to these
really important problems because F
fundamentally that's what science does
right there's
observation new discovery and then you
want to apply your discoveries towards
challenging problems that would improve
everyone's life if you can find a
solution to these problems okay and so
that's the goal so like I like I said
we've walked through the idea of going
from a rainforest all the way to the
point where we have new chemicals in in
the test tube that can be used for these
problems so on the last side I just want
to thank the students and the people
that have been doing this with us for
the past five
years my dad and
Percy uh this is one group of students
this is another group one student
decided when I wasn't there that he was
was going to climb a Vine that was a
horrifically bad idea uh we had a jungle
mud fight that was pretty entertaining
so it's been a great great great bit of
fun um and uh I think some really cool
science and some cool observations have
come out of it so I'd be happy to answer
any questions um but thanks for coming
this Saturday
[Music]
morning